[Musique]
une fois par mois des millions de fans
dans le monde de vivre un moment de joie
et de féliciter les règles elles ont
offert un gros marqueur du sexisme qu'on
pouvait voir dans une société et ça en
l'observent parce que les par exemple
les techniques qui étaient utilisés au
fil du temps pour se protéger pendant
les périodes de menstruation elles ont
énormément évolué et parfois on est
revenu à des choses parfois on en a
laissé par exemple dans l'egypte
ancienne on utilisait des sorte de
tampon en fait puisqu'on a roulé des des
matières textiles c'était pas du coton
le coton il n'existait pas encore mais
de matières textiles autour de bâtonnets
et puis on s'intéresse à l'intérieur du
vagin et ça faisait une forme de tampon
tout ce qui est moyen âge en europe
centrale ça a été un gros tournant on va
dire puisqu'on avait une sorte de deux
visions des règles qui a commencé à
s'imposer comme étant quelque quelque
chose d'un pur quelque chose de sale
avec la montée de la religion on a
considéré que les femmes qui avaient
leurs règles c'était en fait le symbole
du péché initial celui de sève
donc du coup c'était une façon
d'expliquer leurs péchés donc une femme
qui avait ses règles c'était une femme
un pur c'était un être sale et alors là
il y avait deux possibilités soit tu
faisais tu était quelqu'un d'assez aisée
et tu pouvais te fournir des jupons mais
c'était très rare la majorité des femmes
ne le faisait pas la majorité des femmes
travaillaient dans les champs et pour
les paysannes les bains on laissait tout
simplement couler le sang le long des
jambes et ensuite on se les labels le
soir en fait ce qui va permettre de
prendre un autre tournant c'est quand on
va inventer la machine a filé le coton
du coup ça va permettre une plus grosse
production de sous vêtements et petit à
petit les sous-vêtements donc les jupons
etc ont commencé à se répandre et là ça
va permettre d'avoir une forme de
protection au xxème siècle ça a été le
deuxième gros tournant puisque les
femmes ont commencé un petit peu à
s'émanciper tapé du poing sur la table
en disant écoutez là ça vous faire
quelque chose quoi
et donc on a il ya eu l'apparition de
deux choses les premiers tampon jetables
donc les tampons en coton classique est
également
apparition des premières salles est
lavable est alors quand je dis servette
lavables c'était pas du tout ce qu'on
peut voir aujourd'hui avec les jeux les
salles d'aude que vous avez avec des
petits clips et puis c'est tout beau
tout pratique c'était des gros machin
quand on se mettait à l'intérieur comme
une culotte et qui était retenu par des
sangles autour de la taille
donc question praticité on repassera et
ensuite on arrivait à la période moderne
avec les tampons et les serviettes
classique que vous achetez très
probablement si vous êtes une femme
[Musique]
en fait le problème c'est que
littéralement on paye un impôt sur le
fait de posséder un utérus
j'ai pas choisi à la naissance d'être
une femme et pourtant tous les mois je
dois donner de l'argent pour des
protections hygiéniques alors que ça
devrait être quelque chose de gratuit
finalement même dans des pays
occidentaux comme la france on a aussi
des cours aux inégalités par exemple on
peut parler des sdf qui n'ont pas
forcément accès à tous les soins
qu'elles devraient avoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'acheter des
tampons et des serviettes quand on n'a
même pas de quoi s'acheter à manger
aujourd'hui on a la sensation que les
règles sont complètement acceptés dans
notre société c'est quelque chose qui
n'est plus tabou mais c'est pas vraiment
le cas regarder les publicités par
exemple aujourd'hui encore avec à la
télé on montre du liquide bleu sur les
singes et hygiéniques pour faire de la
pub pour les sablettes en question mais
on montre jamais le sang parce que c'est
considéré comme quelque chose de sale
alors que finalement c'est patent
différents que le sens qu'on va montrer
sur un enfant quand il se fait un beau
bourg et km un pansement c'est quelque
chose que au moins 50 % de la population
vit très régulièrement et donc à mon
sens ce serait peut être intéressant de
commencer à réfléchir et à ouvrir un
petit peu nos mars sur ce sujet